- Une population vieillissante,
et de moins en moins d'enfants.
Le gouvernement de Xi Jinping
abolit la limite de deux enfants
par couple pour contrer
la baisse du nombre
de naissances.
"Je pense que c'est une bonne
politique parce que
le vieillissement de
la population est sérieux",
explique cette mère.
"À mon avis, peu importe
où nous vivons, la mentalité est
qu'un enfant est suffisant."
- Les données du dernier
recensement préoccupent
le régime, car elles laissent
entrevoir une crise
de la transition démographique
en Chine. De 14,6 millions
de naissances en 2019, le pays
est passé à 12 millions en 2020,
année pandémique.
SERGE GRANGER, professeur
à l'École de politique appliquée
- À partir de 2027, c'est 100 %
sûr que la population chinoise
va commencer à baisser.
Et là, l'Inde va la surpasser.
Ça, c'est une inquiétude
de Pékin.
À long terme, cela signifie
une pression économique
plus forte sur la population
en âge de travailler.
Plusieurs facteurs expliquent
cette baisse des naissances :
l'augmentation du coût
de la vie, les grossesses
tardives et la politique
de l'enfant unique, assouplie
en 2016, qui a laissé
des traces.
- La politique d'enfant unique
a fait en sorte que beaucoup
de parents ont investi dans
un seul enfant. Et maintenant,
leur disponibilité budgétaire
est plutôt allouée
aux soins de santé.
♪ ♪ ♪
- En trame de fond, c'est
surtout le rêve de Xi Jinping
d'une Chine superpuissante qui
est en jeu, selon cet expert.
- L'Inde va avoir plus
de population que la Chine,
donc les avantages corporatifs,
vous comprenez, vont déménager
en Inde, du point de vue
industriel. Et du point de vue
de l'économie, du savoir,
la population américaine, elle,
va croître de 15 % d'ici 2050.
- Le gouvernement a aussi
annoncé qu'il souhaite repousser
l'âge de la retraite pour faire
face au défi socio-économique
qu'il l'attend.
Ici Mélissa François,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.